interrupting that to go to London the
House of Commons Prime Minister Boris
Johnson with your permission I shall
make a statement on yesterday's Supreme
Court will be ample opportunity for
everybody who wants to question the
Prime Minister in conformity with usual
practice to do so but the statement must
and will be heard the Prime Minister
thank you mr. speaker with your
permission I shall make a statement on
yesterday's Supreme Court verdict and
the way forward for this paralyzed
Parliament voted to leave the European
Union than have ever voted for any party
or proposition in our history parties
promised the public that they would
honor the result sadly many have since
done all they could to abandon those
promises and to overturn that Democratic
vote and after three years of dither and
delay the leftist country at risk of
being locked forever in the orbit of the
EU this government that I lead has been
trying truly to get us out and most
people most people indeed most
supporters of the party opposite
regardless of how they voted three years
ago think the referendum must be
respected they want brexit done I want
brexit done and people want us out on
October the 31st
[Applause]
with a new deal if possible but without
one if necessary 964 days ago I was told
that Brussels would never reopen the
withdrawal agreement we are discussing
area put a withdrawal agreement in the
negotiations the brussels would never
consider alternatives to the backstop
the trap that keeps the UK effectively
in the EU but with no say we're now
discussing those alternatives in the
negotiations I was told
russell's would never consider
arrangements that were not permanent
we're now discussing in the negotiations
an arrangement that works on the
principle of consent and is not
permanent I was told there was no chance
of a new deal but we are discussing a
new deal and this is in spite of the
best efforts of the party opposite and
this partner to wreck our negotiations
off the table the truth is that the
majority in this Parliament the majority
opposite are not are opposed and not
opposed to the so-called No Deal
but this Parliament does not want rich
it to happen at all many of those many
of those who voted for the surrender act
a few weeks ago said then that their
intention was to stop a known deal for
exit they have said every day since that
Parliament must vote against any deal at
all I think the people of this country
can see very clearly
[Applause]
[Music]
people are just sticky waiting wildly I
can scarce be here the Prime Minister
myself and I wish to hear the statement
as other colleagues should also do is
the Prime Minister the people of this
country can see perfectly clearly what
is going on they know that Parliament
does not want to honor its promises to
respect to referendum the people at home
know that this Parliament will keep the
name it will keep sabotaging the
negotiations because they don't want a
deal mr. speaker the truth is that
members opposite are living in a fantasy
[Applause]
this is what they want to do cancel the
first referendum they're going to
legislate for a second referendum and
Parliament will promise that this time
that's not the lady opposite but
Parliament all promise that this time it
really really will respect the public to
remain and everybody will forget the
last few years
Mr Speaker I have to say I think that is
an extraordinary delusion and a fantasy
a fantasy even greater than the
Communist fantasies peddled by the
leader doctors
it will not happen the public the public
don't want another referendum what they
want and what they demand is that we
honor the promise we made to the voters
to respect the first referendum to move
on to put brexit behind us and focus on
the NHS on violent crime and on cutting
the cost of living that is why I brought
forward a Queen's speech this government
intends to present a program for life
after brexit but some members of this
house could not stand that either
instead of facing the voters the
opposition turns tail and fled and fled
from an election instead of deciding to
let the voters decide they ran for the
courts instead and despite the fact that
I followed the exact same process as my
predecessors in courting a Queen's
speech the Supreme Court was asked to
intervene in this process for the first
time ever and it is absolutely no
disrespect to the judiciary to say I
think the court was wrong to pronounce
[Applause]
a political question at a time or
whatever the strength and intensity of
feeling and the passions to which these
matters give rise we must hear what is
being said in the chamber and I wish
dear the Prime Minister the court was
wrong to pronounce on what is
essentially a political question the
time of great national controversy so we
have opposition MPs that block and delay
everything running to the courts to
block and delay even more including
blocking legislation to improve and
invest in our NHS and keeping violent
criminals in jail I think the people
understand outside this house understand
what is happening they know that nothing
can disguise the truth it's not just
that this Parliament is gridlock
paralyzed and refusing to deliver on the
priorities of the people it's not just
unable to move forward it's worse than
that mr. speaker out of sheer
selfishness and political cowardice
[Applause]
willing to move aside and did the people
say they see MPs demanding that the
people should be given a say one week
and then running away from the election
that would provide the people will a say
worst of all they see more ever more
elaborate legal and political maneuvers
from the party opposite which is
determined absolutely determined to say
we know best and thumb their noses at
the seventeen point four million people
who voted to the opposition and his
party do not trust the people the result
whatever the cost
mr. speaker about the bill for hundreds
of millions of pounds that will come
with every week of delay they don't care
if another year or more is wasted in
arguing about a referendum that happened
three years ago all that matters to them
now is an obsessive desire to overrule
the referendum result while we want to
take our country up again to go forward
with a fantastic program an accelerated
program of investment in infrastructure
in health and education and technology
they are throwing on the handbrake well
mr. speaker we will not betray the
people who sent us here
[Music]
that's what they want to do we will not
abandon the priorities that matter to
the public and we will continue to
challenge those opposition parties to
uphold democracy honorable and right
honourable members opposite so disagreed
with this government's commitment to
leaving on October the 31st they had a
very simple remedy at their disposal
they could have voted for a general
election I have to confess mr. speaker
that I was a little shocked to discover
that the party whose members stood up in
Brighton this week and repeatedly and in
the most strident terms demanded an
election I heard them is the very same
party whose members already twice this
month not once but twice refused to
allow the people to the side for two
years they have demanded an election for
twice they have voted against it the
leader of the Opposition changes his
mind so often I wonder whether he
supports an election today or whether
the shadow Chancellor or the shadow
attorney-general
have overruled him again because they
know that the voters will judge their
manifesto for what it is pointless delay
is he going to demand Patty's going to
demand an election and then vote against
it
just as he taught to negotiate a new
brexit deal and then both against that -
is he actually going to vote no
confidence in this government is he
going to dodge a vote of no confidence
in the Prime Minister
in order to escape the verdict of the
voters that's he in his heart even want
to be Prime Minister anymore he says
that I should go to Brussels on 17th of
October and negotiate another pointless
today today but he doesn't want to go
himself even if he did his colleagues
wouldn't let him I was quite frankly
they recoil they recall at the idea of
him negotiating on the people's behalf
representing this country with the like
so Vladimir Putin let alone the EU or
the rulers of Tehran or is it perhaps
that he wants a Conservative government
there would be a curious state of
affairs indeed if Her Majesty's loyal
opposition had every faith in the
government of the day so if in fact the
party opposite does not have confidence
in the government they will have a
chance to prove it
they have until one house rises let them
listen they have until the house rises
today to table a motion of no confidence
in the government
[Applause]
and we can have that vote tomorrow or if
they leave the other parties the smaller
parties will they have the courage to
act or will they refuse to take
responsibility and do nothing but dither
and delay why wouldn't they what are
they scared of mr. speaker order order
I appeal to the house I said to have
some regard to how our proceedings are
viewed by people watching them in the
country at large the order let the
remainder of the statement be heard a
grateful to the Prime Minister's
exhortation but I didn't require it I'm
perfectly content what I want to hear is
the rest of the statement and then
questioning on it the Prime Minister Mr
Speaker well mr. speaker thank you and
as I commend this statement to the house
I say it is time to get brexit done
brexit done so we respect the referendum
get pretty done so we can move on to
deal with the people's priorities the
NHS the cost of living let's get let's
eat done so we can start to reunite this
country after the divisions of the
referendum rather than having another
one it's time for this Parliament
finally to take responsibility for its
decisions we decided to call that
referendum we promised we promised time
and again to respect it I think the
people of this country have had enough
of it this Parliament must either stand
aside and let this government get Rexach
done or bring a vote of confidence and
finally face the day of reckoning with
the voters
commend his statement to the heart
let me go
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Thank You mr. Speaker I thank
the Prime Minister for an advanced copy
of his statement unfortunately it was
like his illegal shutting down of
Parliament know of no effect and should
be quashed in the words of the Supreme
Court this mr. speaker was 10 minutes of
bluster from a dangerous prime minister
who thinks he is above the law but in
truth mr. speaker in truth mr. speaker
is not fit for the office which he holds
[Applause]
mr. speaker I'm glad to see so many
colleagues back here doing what they
were elected to do holding the
government to account for its failings
whether it's the attempts to shut down
democracy its sham brexit negotiations
it's chaotic and inadequate No Deal
preparations its allegations of
corruption its failure on climate change
its failure to step in to save Thomas
Cook this government this government mr.
speaker is failing the people of Britain
and the people of Britain no it's
oh I said that the Prime Minister
shouldn't be shouted down the same goes
for the leader of the Opposition and let
me say to people bellowing from a
sedentary position
stop it you will exhaust your vocal
cords you will get nowhere it won't work
and these proceedings will continue for
as long as is necessary for the chair to
be satisfied the proper scrutiny has
taken place
Eadie's as simple and incontrovertible
as that brings Jeremy Corbyn Thank You
mr. speaker
yesterday's Supreme Court verdict
represents an extraordinary and I
believe precarious moment in this
country's history the highest court in
this land has found the Prime Minister
broke the law when he tried to
when he tried to shut down our
democratic accountability at a crucial
moment in our public life the judges
concluded there was no reason and I
quote let alone a good reason for the
prime minister to have shut down
Parliament after yesterday's ruling mr.
speaker
the Prime Minister should have done the
honorable thing and resigned
[Applause]
yet mr. speaker here he is forced back
to this house to rightfully face the
scrutiny he tried to avoid with no shred
of remorse or humility and of course no
substance whatsoever so let's see if he
will answer some questions does the
Prime Minister agree with his attorney
general that the government got it wrong
or with the leader of the house that the
Supreme Court the Supreme Court
committed a constitutional coup this mr.
speaker is a vital question about
whether the government respects the
judiciary or not the Attorney General
was also categorical that the government
would comply with the EU withdrawal
number to act can the Prime Minister
confirm that mr. speaker
Mr Speaker I want to pay tribute to
those MPs from all parties across the
house the Lords and in the Scottish
Parliament and the Welsh Assembly who
have not only fought so hard to stop a
disastrous no deal but continued to take
the case against prorogation
through the courts the government has
failed to silence our democracy mr.
speaker mr. speaker during a period of
unlawful prorogation the government was
forced to release their yellowhammer no
deal analysis and plans no wonder
the Prime Minister has been so eager to
avoid scrutiny and so eager to hide the
dangers of his brexit plan the release
of those documents leads to many
questions the government must now answer
that our Parliament is back in operation
so I would like to start by asking the
Prime Minister why
[Applause]
I would like to start mr. speaker by
asking the Prime Minister why the
government described leaked yellowhammer
documents in August as being out of date
when the documents were later produced
in September they were word-for-word the
same documents it is clear they have
tried to hide from the people the truth
the real truth of a No Deal prexy